[Music]
hello everyone welcome to live coding a
machine learning model from scratch my
name is Sarah Robinson I'm a developer
advocate on the cloud platform team
focused on machine learning you can find
me on twitter at s rob tweets and most
recently you can find my blog at Sarah
Robinson dev so let's dive right in with
what we're gonna cover today I'm gonna
start out with a quick overview of what
machine learning is then I'll talk about
the model we'll be building and finally
we'll get to the live coding so at a
high level what is machine learning I
really like this definition using data
to answer questions the idea here is
that as we provide more and more data to
our machine learning systems they'll be
able to improve and generalize on
examples that they haven't seen before
so we can think of almost any supervised
learning problem in this way we have our
labeled training inputs we feed them
into our model and our model outputs a
prediction now these training inputs
could really be anything it could be the
text of a movie review and our model
could be doing sentiment analysis to
tell us that this is a positive review
it could be numerical or categorical
fitness data and maybe our model
predicts the quality of the sleep that
we'll get it could be image data so in
this example our model is predicting
that this is an image of a cat so this
model concept can seem really magical
but it's actually not magic under the
hood it all boils down to matrix
multiplication so if any of you remember
y equals MX plus B from your algebra
classes this might look familiar
so the idea here is that you have your
features as matrices those your inputs
and then you have the thing you're
trying to predict and then you have
these weight and bias matrices and when
these are initialized they're
initialized to random values so the idea
here is that as you train your model
you'll find the optimal values for these
weight and bias matrices so that you get
high accuracy predictions so that sounds
great but you might be thinking the
examples I showed in the previous
it's none of those had matrices anywhere
well it turns out that you can represent
pretty much any type of data as a matrix
so this image as an example all an image
really is is just a bunch of pixels and
this is a color image so each pixel has
a red green and blue value or an RGB
value so this image becomes three
matrices of the RGB values for each
pixel let's say you have categorical
data so for a particular column in your
data set it describes the industry that
a person works in and there's three
possible values the way you encode
categorical data is through what's
called one hot encoding so to do this we
create an array with the number of
elements corresponding to the number of
categories you have in this case three
and all of the values are zero except
for a single one and the index of that
one corresponds with the value of that
category so maybe you're thinking
wouldn't it be easier if we just
numerically encoded these healthcare one
finance to retail three we could do that
but then our model would interpret these
as continuous numerical values so it
would assign higher weight to retail I
would say retail is greater than finance
which is greater than healthcare and we
want our model to treat all these inputs
equally which is why we one-hot encode
them so I've shown you how we can
transform our data for our machine
learning models in this talk I want to
share with you some tools on Google
cloud that can help you build ml models
and I like to visualize this as a
pyramid where you can choose your level
of abstraction if you want to get down
to the details of matrix multiplication
and building all the layers for your
model from scratch which we're gonna do
today you can do that but you also don't
need ml expertise to get started so the
tools on the bottom of the pyramid are
targeted more towards data scientists
and ml engineers and as we move towards
the top these are targeted towards
application developers that may not have
machine learning expertise so in this
talk we're gonna be building a model
with tensorflow
and we're gonna deploy it on cloud a AI
platform the idea here
to turn you all into data scientists and
m/l engineers so when I was thinking
about type of model I wanted to build
for this I wanted to choose something
that would resonate with developers and
as a developer there's one school I can
think of that I use on a daily basis and
that is Stack Overflow so I wanted to
build a text classification model to see
if we could predict the tags of a stack
overflow question to do this we need a
lot of data and luckily we have a public
data set available in Google Cloud
bigquery which is our big data analytics
warehouse on Google cloud platform
McCrory has lots of really interesting
public data sets for you to explore and
play with and they happen to have one of
Stack Overflow questions and it doesn't
have just a few Stack Overflow questions
it has over 26 gigabytes and over 17
million rows of questions so this is a
great place to get started since we
don't have a ton of time I wanted to
simplify the problem space so in this
example we're just gonna be classifying
questions that have these five tags
related to data science and machine
learning so for this particular question
our model should categorize it as pandas
which is a Python library for data
science so our first step is to get the
data from bigquery bigquery has a great
web UI where we can write sequel
directly in the browser get our data and
then download it as a CSV which is what
I did
so I'm extracting the title and the body
of the question concatenated them into
one field getting a comma separated
string of the tags and then we're only
getting tags with these questions with
these five tags so I ran this query and
as I was looking at the results I
noticed something a lot of the questions
the question posters conveniently we'll
put the name of whatever framework
they're using in the question which is
very helpful that got me thinking do we
actually need machine learning for this
could we just replace our entire ml
system with an if statement if
tensorflow is in the question tag equal
sensor foil the answer is no because
although lots of question posters do
this there are a lot of people that
questions that are really good questions
but they just dive right into the code
and they may not mention the framework
or tad name so we want to capture these
questions too and we don't want our
model to just pick up on those signal
words so that it only identifies
questions with the name with the word
tensorflow in them as tensorflow we
wanted to be able to generalize to find
patterns among these tags so when I was
pre-processing the training data what I
wanted to do was take out these obvious
keywords so I thought I could replace
them with a common word and because
everybody loves avocados I replaced all
of these words including abbreviations
for the frameworks with the word avocado
so the results in bigquery looks
something like this we have our
questions we have avocado predictive
models we have avocado data sets
lots of avocados everywhere so what I
didn't talk about before was how we
encode freeform text data into matrices
there's a couple different approaches
for doing this I'm gonna use one called
bag of words and this is a really simple
one for getting started so you can think
of each input to your model in bag of
words as a bag of Scrabble tiles whereas
instead of a letter on each tile you
have a word on each tile so this type of
model cannot detect the order of words
in a sentence but it can detect the
presence or absence of certain words so
to show you how this works
I want to show you a really simple
example so for this example we'll limit
our problem space even further to say
we're only tagging questions with three
types of tags and bag of word models
have a concept called vocabulary so for
pretend for a moment that you're
learning English for the first time and
you only know these ten words that's how
our models gonna look at the problem
might lead to some interesting
conversations every time we only know
these ten words so when we take this
input question how to plot data frame
bar graph we'll look at our vocabulary
and we'll say okay I recognize these
three words the rest of the words in the
question are gonna be gibberish to the
model and when we feed this what
all of our questions into our model we
want to feed them in as matrices that
are the same size so what we do is our
question becomes an array the size of
our vocabulary with ones and zeroes
indicating which words from our
vocabulary are present so because data
frame is the first index in our
vocabulary the first element of our
array becomes a 1
even though data frame is not the first
word in our question same goes for graph
and plot so to summarize our question
becomes a vocabulary sized array of ones
and zeros it's called multi hat encoding
and our prediction since for this
particular model our models going to be
able to identify a question that has
multiple tags not just one so this will
also be a multi hot array so now we know
how to encode our text data for our
model what does our model actually look
like so the input data to our model is
going to be that vocabulary sized bag of
words matrix and then we feed that into
what's called hidden layers so this is
going to be a deep neural network which
means that we have layers in between our
input and our output layer so it's gonna
take this vocabulary sized array and
resize it to whatever size we choose for
our second layer and our third layer now
the output of these hidden layers
doesn't mean too much to us our models
using it to represent complex
relationships but what we really care
about is the output of our final layer
there's many options for how you can
compute the output of this layer we're
going to choose one called sigmoid and
what this will do is it will return a
value between 0 & 1 for each tag which
corresponds to the probability that that
tag is associated with this question so
for this particular example it looks
like the question has a high probability
of being about chaos or tensorflow
so what are all the tools we're going to
use to build this I already showed you
how we use bigquery to gather our data
and downloaded the CSV we're gonna use 3
open source frameworks to do some
pre-processing and some transformations
on our data to get it into the right
format will use pandas scikit-learn and
we'll use tensorflow to build our model
specifically TF chaos we will run our
training and evaluation in collab collab
is a Python notebook that's cloud hosted
and you can run it in the browser it's
totally free for anyone to use and
finally we'll deploy our model on cloud
a AI platform so the title says live
coding let's go over to the demo can we
switch to the demo awesome okay so here
we have our collab notebook it's
connected again anybody can access
collab in the browser collab dot
research Google com
and as you can see we've got no code in
here what could go wrong just a bunch of
comments so I am going to start writing
some code and run these cell-by-cell so
what I'm gonna use is collab has this
handy snippets tool so I've saved a
couple of the snippets for this notebook
that I'm just gonna drop in here so the
first one is we are going to run this
anyway
alright had to reset the runtime and now
we are connected so our first cell is
just importing all the libraries we're
going to use we're using tensorflow
pandas and um hi a couple of
scikit-learn utility functions and then
we're using care us to build our model
so we've got all of our imports let me
actually make that just a tad bigger so
that you can all see the next thing we
want to do is authenticate here we go
so collab also has a handy
authentication function that we can run
and what this will do is will pop up a
URL for us to authenticate to our cloud
account so i will allow access copy this
code and paste it in okay so now we are
authenticated and now we're gonna get to
the fun stuff so first we want to
download our CSV so now that imma
sonicated I have saved all this data in
a CSV in Google Cloud storage
that's our object storage tool on Google
cloud platform
so I'm going to download the CSV to my
local collab instance and then what I'm
going to do is I'm going to use pandas
to read this CSV in so let me just read
it in here and this will transform our
data into what's called a panda's data
frame which you'll see in a moment the
next thing we're gonna do is we're going
to shuffle our data and this is a really
important concept in machine learning in
case your data was in any sort of order
before you want to make sure that you
shuffle it and I'm using the
scikit-learn shuffle function to do that
data dot head will let us preview our
data so this is what our data looks like
we've got our tags as comma separated
strings and we've got our question text
with lots of avocados now we can't feed
this in its current form to our model so
we're gonna need to do some encoding so
first we'll take care of the tags so the
first thing we want to do is encode
these tags as we saw on the slides to
multi hot five element arrays because we
have five possible tags so what I'm
doing in the first line is I'm splitting
each tag into an array of strings and
then I'm using this scikit-learn
multi-label binarize ER function which
will take all of those arrays of strings
and transform them into a multi hot
array so this is for the first question
we can see it's about tensorflow
and care us and here's this reference
array that Saiki learners created for us
so our input becomes this so we've
encoded our labels and we are almost
ready to move on to the questions before
we do that we need to split our data so
another important concept in machine
learning is train test split so we take
most of our data majority of our data
and we'll use it for training our model
in this case we'll do 80% we set aside
smaller portion of our data it's used
for testing so that we can see how our
model performs on data
that it has never seen before so in this
case we have a hundred and fifty
thousand questions in our training set
and thirty-seven thousand in our test
set so we will now split our labels into
training and test sets and we'll say
test tags equals tags encoded we'll run
that so we've got our labels ready to go
and the next thing we want to do so our
our label data is ready to go now we
need to encode our question data into
bag-of-words
matrices so I've written a class to do
this I'll paste that in here it looks
like a lot going on but I'll explain so
what's happening here is we're using
this chaos tokenizer utility so luckily
we don't have to do all that code of
converting our freeform text to bag of
words by hand
caris has this utility that'll do it for
us all we do is pass it or vocabulary
size so in this super simple example
that I showed before we had a vocabulary
size of ten so that I'll take the top
ten words from our data set since this
data set is way bigger
I chose a vocab size of 400 which you'll
see in a moment so you want to choose
something that's not so small that it
only identifies common words across all
of your questions but you also don't
want to choose something that's too big
that your bag of words arrays become all
ones so we'll run this and now we're
actually going to use that class so we
will import it and we will split our
questions in to train and test sets so
I'll do that right now there's still
strings we haven't encoded them yet okay
so the next step is to instantiate a
vocab sized variable which is going to
be 400 and now we will actually tokenize
that text so we're gonna create a
variable called processor and in
then she ate that text preprocessor
class passing it our vocab sighs and now
we can call processor dot create
tokenizer and pass it our trained
questions that's this method right here
and then finally the last part is
actually creating those bag-of-words
matrices so this will be equal to
processor dot transform text that method
right there and we'll pass that our
trained questions and then the test set
will be the same with our test questions
which we defined up here so I'm gonna
run that it's gonna take a bit of time
to run because what it's doing is its
transforming all 180,000 of our
questions from text to bag of words so
while that's running we can keep writing
the other cells and they'll run when
this one completes so what I want to do
is print the length of the first
instance should be 400 and then we're
just gonna log that bag of words matrix
so that you can see it and now we get to
building our model we'll come back to
this when it finishes running so the
next thing that we want to do is save
that tokenizer that we created because
we're gonna need it when we deploy our
model we're using a python utility
called pickle to save that tokenizer
object to a file so now it's time to
create our model we've transformed our
data we've saved our tokenizer now we
actually want to write the code to our
model using Kerris I'm gonna wrap this
in a method we'll call it create model
and it'll take our vocabulary size and
our number of tags and we're gonna use
the chaos sequential model API to do
that which I imported above this is my
favorite API for building models because
it essentially lets you define your
models as a stack of layers so you'll
see that the code we're about to write
will correspond really nicely to that
model diagram that
just showed okay so it looks like this
cell finish running so we can see that
this is what the first bag-of-words
input looks like for our first question
sarey of ones and zeros so let's
continue building our model so the first
layer to our model is going to be a
dense fully connected layer that just
means that every neuron an input layer
is connected to every neuron in the
output layer we need to tell our first
layer what the input shape is going to
be in this case it'll be the input of
our vocab size which is 400 and then
finally we need to tell care us how to
compute the output of this layer the
great thing about chaos is we don't need
to know exactly how this activation
function works under the hood we just
need to know the correct activation
function to use so in this case Ray Lu
is what we'll be using will add one more
hidden layer also with the rail of
activation function
we don't need input shape here because
it'll infer it from the previous layer
so so far these are our hidden layers so
we don't care too much about the output
of those layers but we do care about is
the output of our final layer when that
layer is gonna have five neurons it'll
be a five element array since we have
five tags in our data set and the
activation function here will be sigmoid
so that's really all the code for our
model just four lines of code we've
defined our model in care us we need to
run model compile so that we can
actually train and evaluate this model
and to do this we need to tell it a
couple of things so we need to tell it
our loss function this is how Kaos will
compute the error of our model so every
time it runs training it'll use this
function to say okay what was the error
between what the model predicted and the
ground truth what it should have
predicted again we don't need to know
exactly how this particular loss
function works under the hood this is
just the best one to use for this type
of model I also need to tell it my
optimizer the optimizer is how the model
will update the way
after it goes through a set of data and
then finally I want to tell it how to
evaluate my model as its training and
we're gonna use accuracy as a metric
here so I will return my model and now
we'll actually create our model so we'll
call create model we'll pass at our boat
capsized and our num tags and then we
can use this model dot summary method to
see what our model looks like layer by
layer so we can run that we've got our
model ready to go we have not trained it
yet so the next thing we'll do is we'll
train our model and we can do that with
one method call just model dot set we
pass it a couple of things we pass it
our bag of words array that's our input
our features we pass it our labels those
are the tags which we've encoded we need
to tell it how many packs to run
training for what this means is that
this is how many times our model will
iterate over our entire data set so
we'll go through our entire data set
three times batch size is how many
elements our model will look at at one
time before it updates the weights in
this case we'll use 128 and then I'm
gonna pass an optional parameter called
validation split which will take 10% of
our training data and evaluate it as our
model is training so we're gonna run
training and it should train pretty fast
and what we ideally see here is that our
validation and our training loss is
decreasing so that's a good sign we've
got our validation and training loss
decreasing if your validation loss is
increasing as your training loss is
decreasing it might be a sign that your
model is learning the training data too
closely we can see that our accuracy is
96% which is pretty good so next step is
evaluating our model so that 20% of the
questions that we set aside we're now
gonna see how our model performs on that
data so we call model evaluate we pass
it our test bag of words
our test tags
and we tell it our batch size and our
evaluation accuracy is very close to our
training accuracy which is a good sign
and then the last thing we want to do is
save our model to a file
caris uses the h5 file format so we'll
save our model and now we're gonna test
it out locally so we have a custom
prediction class that I've written and
all this is going to do is pre process
our data so it'll instantiate our model
our saved model from the file it'll
instantiate our tokenizer it'll take the
question as text transform it and then
return a prediction that's sigmoid
probability array so let's save some
questions to predict this is just an
array of two sample questions and then
we will make a prediction on our local
model so this should return cool so that
for the first question it predicted
chaos which was accurate second one
predicted pandas so we've got our model
working locally accuracy is 96 percent
next thing we want to do is package and
deploy it to AI platform so I've written
some code to do this and one of the
features that we're gonna make use of
that's new to cloudy I platform is
custom code which lets us write custom
server-side Python code that's run at
prediction time now this is really
useful because it'll let us keep our
client super simple so our client will
just pass the text to our model we don't
have to do any transformations on the
client we'll pass our text to the model
and on the server will transform that
text to bag-of-words
and then return the correct tags so to
do this we'll need to copy some files to
Google Cloud storage so that cloudy I
platform can find our model and our
tokenizer I'm going to use the Google
cloud CLI G cloud to set my current
project to the one I've configured for
this demo
and finally we want to deploy this to AI
platform so here's the deploy command
that we're going to run we're gonna set
our minimum nodes to one so that our
model doesn't scale to zero and I'm
gonna create a new version called IO 19
and we are gonna deploy that that'll
take a couple of minutes to run but if I
look over here in the cloudy I platform
model UI we can see that my model is
deploying which is pretty cool
so while that's deploying let's go back
to the slides so we built something that
looks pretty good we've written some
code to pre-process our data we've
trained a model with pretty high
accuracy but can we do better
right now our model is pretty much a
black box we don't know how it's making
predictions we know that the predictions
are accurate but we don't know what's
making it make those conclusions so as
sundar mentioned in the keynote we want
to make sure that our model is using
data to make predictions in a way that's
fair to all of our model users to do
that we need to uncover the black box
and as model builders we need to
remember that we're responsible for the
predictions generated by our model this
may sound really obvious but we need to
say take steps to avoid bias by making
sure that our training data is
representative of the people that are
using our model luckily there's a lot of
great tools to help you do this I'm
gonna look at one open-source tool
called shop and what shop will let us do
is interpret the output of any machine
learning model so we'll use it here for
our TF chaos model but we could use it
for any type of model the way shop works
is we'll create what's called an
explainer object passing in our model
and a subset of our training data and
then Shapp returns these attribution
values so what the attribution values
are is it's positive and negative values
indicating how much a particular feature
impacted our models prediction so let's
say we had a model with three feature
we get back a three element array of
attribution values high positive values
I mean then that particular feature
pushed our prediction up negative values
would mean it pushed our prediction down
well how will this work for our bag of
words model so what I configured shop to
do was I had it treat that 400 element
vocabulary array as 400 features and so
we get back 400 different attribution
scores and we can take the highest
values from that and the lowest values
to see which words had the most impact
on our model so I wrote a little code to
do this I don't know if the colors are
showing up well in there but what this
is is I took the top five highest and
lowest attribution scores so that I
could see which words our model is using
to make predictions so this particular
question is about pandas and it picked
up on the words column data frame D F
series which is good because those are
all words that are specific to pandas
words that contribute at least were for
each and you which are fairly common
words that you might find in any stack
overflow question so this is a good sign
that our model is working correctly so
let's go back to the demo and take a
look at shap so it looks like our model
finished deploying I'm going to go ahead
and set that as the default version and
before we get into shop we will generate
some predictions on our deployed model
so I'm going to write a file with some
test predictions and now we're going to
use the Google cloud CLI to get some
predictions on our train model so we
call G cloud AI platform predict we pass
it our model name which is stack o model
and we pass it our text instances which
is this predictions dot txt file that we
just saved
and we will run that and
now we are going to print our deployed
model predictions so it looks good our
model we're calling our model that's
deployed on AI platform and it has
predicted chaos successfully for the
first question and pandas for the second
question so now let's use shop to
explain our model so shop does not call
does not come pre-installed in collab so
we will install it be a pip and then we
will also install this module called
coloured which I use to color the text
to different words of the text so once
that's done installing we will import
shop and we can create our explainer so
we will create what's called a deep
explainer shop has many different types
of explainers we're gonna use the deep
explainer and we're gonna pass it a
subset of our training data and then we
will create our array of attribution
values so we can call explainer dot shap
values and we pass it a subset of our
tests data in this case we'll just take
the first 25 examples from our test set
so we've got our attribution values the
next thing you want to do is print them
in a nice way so first to do that we're
gonna take that tokenizer that we
created in care US which is a dictionary
and we're gonna convert it to an array
so that we can take our attribution
values from shop and see which word they
correspond to so we'll convert our
tokenizer to a word list and here we can
see the top most frequently occurring
words that our model is our model
vocabularies using and the first thing
we want to do is print a summary plot
which is a method we have in shop to see
a summary of the words that are most
impactful on our models predictions so
we'll pass it our shop values we'll also
need to pass it our feature names which
is that word list we just created and
along with our class names
which goes all the way back to our tag
encoder so if I wrote that correctly we
should get this nice plot here and what
this tells us is the highest magnitude
words that our model is looking at so it
looks like data frame was the word that
our model used most to make predictions
probably because panda there was the
most pandas questions in our model and
we can see that data frame was most
impactful for pandas it was also a
signal word for the other libraries
probably a negative signal word and then
we can see the other words that were
impactful here so plot was most
important in matplotlib predictions
which makes sense and we can see all
these other words down the list so that
gives us a nice aggregate view of how
our model is making predictions for this
particular data set and now if we want
to highlight individual words I've
written some code to do that so that we
can see for a particular question which
words are signalling predictions so
here's an example of a panda's question
the words column a lot of pandas
dataframes have columns that have not a
number of values and then we see common
words like use and does are not being
used by our model to make the
predictions for tensorflow
we get it looking at words like session
sash ops tensor here's a car house
example looks like the most common words
or lsdm layers dents etc so now we can
see how we can use shop to make sure
that our model is behaving correctly one
way you might want to use this in in a
fairness example is if you have a model
that's doing sentiment analysis you want
to make sure that it's using the right
characteristics to predict positive and
negative things and whatever type of
text you're using so if we could go back
to the slides
to wrap things up we're gonna put this
all together and get predictions from
our model in a web app so it'd be really
useful if we could as we're typing a
stack overflow question see which tags
are associated with it so with the help
of my teammate Jennifer person should
follow her on Twitter we built a Chrome
extension and what the Chrome extension
does is it takes the HTML of our stack
overflow question it passes it to a
cloud function which I've written using
the cloud functions Python runtime the
function will use the AI platform API to
make a prediction on our model and then
in our function will return just the
name of high confidence tags back to our
Chrome extension so let's see it in
action let's go back to the demo here we
go okay so here is an example question
about matplotlib in pandas I have just
loaded up my chrome extension locally
looks like it's not working at the
moment hold on one second live demos you
never know let's try it out once more
all right something's going on here I'll
try out the question draft all right not
working but luckily I have a video of
what it was supposed to do sorry about
that everyone
I always have a backup okay so this was
is what it was supposed to do live demos
you never know okay so I was supposed to
predict matplotlib and pandas for this
question and then we have a question
that I've drafted based on the code that
I wrote and a predicted chaos for that
one I'm sorry that the demo didn't work
let's give it one more shot
yeah okay looks like it's not working
anyway that's what the demo was supposed
to do uh if we could go back to the
slides so I covered a lot of different
tools today I just wanted to give a
summary of everything we built we built
a custom text
classification model using TF chaos we
deployed our model on cloudy I platform
I should also mention that I could have
also deployed that shap code to AI
platform using the custom code feature
but in this case I decided just to keep
it super simple and do that part
separately we explained our model output
using shap to make sure that our model
was behaving in the way that we expected
and we kind of called AI platform with
cloud functions you saw a video of what
it was supposed to do
these are links to all of the code that
I showed today and all the different
products so the first link goes to a
github repo with the code for everything
I showed the other links are to various
products that I covered and finally we
are working on model interpretability
support in cloudy i platform so if you
have a use case for it if you want to
stay in the loop and hear more about it
we'd love to hear from you so please
fill out this form at the bitly link at
the bottom and finally please fill out
the feedback on this talk in your i/o
application I really use that a lot to
make the talk better the next time so
thanks everyone
[Music]
you